that's your brother's name that is my
brother's name um oh that is your
brother he has a great name
I'm very excited to be here I love your
work so much and uh this is very
important your work and it's very
amazing so just congratulations on the
podcast and maybe you're being sarcastic
no no I am being when you got to the
very important part no no
because I need a laugh we need a laugh
and and you guys bring us labs uh my
question is and for for the three of you
who what is your favorite film and I
know this is putting you on the spot but
like what do you have or an answer for
that yeah
that's a tough question but I think
honestly my favorite film is Casino
Royale
that's a good answer yeah Daniel Craig
and you know Bond it's just it makes me
happy oh geez I mean it it's a hard
question for me I'm I do separate it I
think I've talked about this I separated
in genres so you know like my favorite
comedies Galaxy Quest my favorite
rom-com is Moonstruck my favorite uh
kind of dramedy I guess would be
adaptation I don't know what about
famous uh what's your favorite male
stripper movie oh that's a tough one
um I would say Magic Mike
um no but Magic Mike came out I just you
you went missing for a couple of weeks
well we did a bit because
Magic Mike show came out yes that one I
like more because Joe manganello has
that very great scene in the liquor
store where he's trying to make the girl
smile so he's just like strip teasing
with a bottle of Coke
and I'm like I get this this is this is
real Cinema yeah I don't know about you
guys but I would watch I would so I
would never miss an episode if Sona had
a movie critics show yes I would watch
it well we've talked about I would like
I like everything so I would be like
that was a good movie there was lighting
and they did it and someone wrote it and
they shot it and that's exciting yeah we
have this happened all the time where on
The Late Night show when we would go and
look at movies yeah you would always
come with me and I'd see them and you
know you whatever I'm a human being
somewhat Discerning and but but you know
so you watch things and you'd be like
that one was okay but and every time we
watched anything son was like that was
fantastic
and I would say really you liked glip
glorp and the and well and the flip-flop
and you would say it didn't cost me
anything and those people made that
they made it and it was on the screen
and it started and then two hours later
it ended and now I'm having wine that
you're paying for yes
that does sound good it does it's nice
what about you you know I would say I
think I sometimes I think of it as and
this sounds morbid but like what's your
like you have like a day to live and I
think of it not and I think trying to
think of it in a positive way like it's
the end of my life and I get to have no
but I just get to like here's what I
think of what's the food I want I want
like a really good pinot noir I want a
really good you know pizza from Naples
and I think I want to watch The
Godfather uh and I know that that's a
movie that a lot of people say but that
that uh and and if I can get Godfather
one and two and make it one movie oh
that's definitely my answer it's your
last day yeah you're gonna lose some
precious time if you do that wait this
isn't for four years okay uh but
um why are you laughing everyone's
laughing everyone's laughing at your dad
well
let's go ahead and cue up The Godfather